hey everybody I'm back
it's a letter
there's a lot of time I mean it's been
the old day feeling like this is when
they find out that I'm not really that
good at what I do
my dreams I'm serious what whenever I do
something goes like you know outside of
the daily show if I do like you know
fouling or any of the shows like that
any of this the kind of the late shows
right night Larry one more all of it I'm
too nervous
good nervous yeah because I think yeah
because it's how is that well because
I'm I just wanted to go well right and
I'm in this it's different kind of a
show has a different rhythm and I'd not
done Bill show so well I went very well
tonight I mean I did it way way back I
know it's a lot of fun when it went fine
it worked really well it went so well I
probably drank too much what have you
just done inside outside yeah and how
was that process I was no chick Jordan
am heard it's gonna be an amazing film
it's big
they're pretty remarkable it's the most
it's the most remarkable creative
experience I've ever been involved with
I've set up my own work out Noah and I
film are no no I'm serious it's a
five-year process are you you watch the
entire creative process take place
there's nowhere else in terms of what
any of us do where you're kind of
experience the the whole process and
that's really something and they're and
they're really growing and and they're
not bothered by the industry doesn't
they're up being away from here you know
very few things you can do no but five
years and I have it put their Scout up
here yeah exactly
speaking of five year processes you are
a winemaker well not really alright I'm
a winery and all for the wine
yes your whiner no good no I um you're
heavily involved with the Cystic
Fibrosis Foundation yes and in about
four years ago four years ago a friend
of mine bid on a kind of thing that we
would go and make a wine a pinot noir no
more now we're we're we're up to 50
cases and now we can begin to send them
out in a couple of months to - this is
pretty much everything yes pretty much
and then they could auction off either
bottle by bottle or a case whatever it
takes to continue to to get money so if
people are watching this they can go to
their local Cystic if they go to this if
they go to their local cystic fibrosis
foundation is where they can you know
you know where they can bid on or
purchase one of these bottles that's
great and the thing is it's really
[ __ ] good one okay it's that simple
I'm not now I believe this is what we're
having right because that what I'm
drinking right now delightful
this one no this isn't it this is just
whatever we also Marty its I want to get
into the spots often without being
piquant Oh tell me about this how do you
feel about wine tasting and you do like
those [ __ ] you like it you don't
like it but I've got friends who were
like my friend who I helped make this
with who's gotten better than it I'm
like too much about really that's tasty
quiet you don't get into the fruity
notes no and you play chamois you know
it tastes like shrub I see this in touch
with licorice I think there's muscles no
there's yeah I'm on board with that yeah
this is a good but I do it when I have
really friends who really get it and in
their freakish because you somebody says
it and then and then I go and I'll taste
like oh well yeah I taste that because
you [ __ ] said it so it's not a
completely made-up thing it's no there's
people who your people are more attuned
to us you tuned to that I've been
alcoholics like I thought they're just
bullshitting me but turns out I'm just
bad
it no you just know you're just a drunk
I'm just interested I don't know what
you're talking about
if I were a drunk I would be drinking at
work on the job check it out
Louis no our cystic fibrosis foundation
yeah and you can go to my website and
check it out Louis black calm and then
we'll direct you to where to get a
bottle of absolutely and you know while
you're on the internet go see where the
ranch's Dew Tour is stopping by your
you're doing stand-up around the country
yeah you want a New Hampshire next one
yeah actually very good oh wow after
that I'm going to a Hampton Beach casino
well one of the first places YouTube
played in the country in the Rolling
Stones are really it old old space in in
in in New Hampshire and then Portland
Maine and Hyannis and then and then
somewhere else very nice to check it out
Lewis Black comm let's find you thank
you sir
pleasure